a lot of boys are trash and I stand by
that statement
my name is Fat Tony I'm a Nigerian
American originally from Houston Texas
I'm an artist rapper host DJ all sorts
of [ __ ] I'm just furious and if you have
a romantic conundrum we have a rapper
here to answer those questions for you
talk to me what's the worst date you've
ever been on the worst day I've ever
been on
I once went out with this girl and we
were just like talking about like people
that I knew who are other artists and
stuff and she figured out that I was
friends with this one guy too she was a
big fan of and she would not stop
talking about him all night like the
rest of the night she would only talk
about this pole she put up this fools
Instagram just like and I'm here looking
like a sucker do you find that like apps
like Instagram or even Twitter work
better than formalized dating apps like
tinder or I'd say far as dating goes
I prefer Instagram because you can
really see a person style I can see your
sense of humor from your social media
like it just it just shows a lot more
about the person then I think swiping
through endless faces right do you have
any tips for people who have a habit of
dating musicians asking for a friend
you know what I think that music people
like myself tune have a bad rep you know
and I don't think that it's entirely
true some of it is based on a little
truth to keep it real the two of us have
experience that would dispute that fact
don't count them out though don't count
us artists out cuz we're all bad and you
know even when we are bad we're bad all
the time you know you gotta take the
good with the best for time and we cool
not all musicians not all of us some of
these people who are like these like
Entertainer types these people who are
kind of for themselves a little bit at
least they can offer you a little bit of
fun you know what I mean they ain't
gonna give you the same old boring you
I have no money I'm not funny I live in
a studio apartment with two other guys
and now Tony is gonna answer some
anonymously submitted questions from the
audience we have a question from someone
who calls herself misanthrope
and her problem is that she's not in a
relationship how do I learn to be more
comfortable being hashtag forever alone
especially around the holidays when it's
impossible to avoid offensive questions
like why aren't you dating and why don't
you have a boyfriend and are you a
lesbian well I think all those questions
are rude is you need to slap whoever
said them to you because it's none of
their business
about your relationship status your
sexuality or any of that that's
completely up to you and you alone now
far as getting comfortable with being
forever alone I feel like that's kind of
a dangerous thought process and the
dangerous space to be in emotionally I
don't think you should view it as like
this negative terrible thing because
being in a relationship isn't everything
and I doubt anybody that really cares
about you your well-being is gonna ask
you why don't you have a boyfriend and
are you a lesbian we have a question
from someone named rom-com lover single
and now resorting to dating apps because
the guys at bars are too young what's a
good opening line to use on dating apps
I'd be direct to say hey what up you
know if there's something on their
profile that you're a fan of I can
relate to maybe lead in with that just
don't come off if we need that cheesy
rom-com [ __ ] that you're a fan of we
have a question from someone named
scrawny and [ __ ] named carnie and
[ __ ] would like to know should I be
friends with my ex I think it all
depends on the circumstances of how your
relationship ended and on the
personality of your ex if your ex is
trash toxic bad for your life get rid of
them my best advice is that you trust
your gut trust your instincts if you
feel funny about a situation listen to
that if you feel good about a situation
listen to
and don't play yourself I am NOT my
partner never helps with dishes cleaning
bathrooms daily housing upkeep
I've spoken with her about this issue on
several different occasions one time I
was mean several times I was nice about
it she still doesn't help keep the space
clean how do we get her to help out
around the apartment more without
constantly nagging her Oh
thing is if you're living together
you're not helping out you living there
that means you should do the thing I
think that you need to have a serious
talk with your partner and let her know
that she has to contribute and I know
you might feel like you're nagging them
I feel like the goal of most
relationships is that you want them to
grow you want to stay with this person
and keep going like different levels you
know you like living this home now maybe
you want to get a bigger home later
maybe you want to start a family later
who knows with all those homes comes a
shitload of dishes and a bunch of dust
and a bunch of dirt and you've got to
clean it up bottom line so nag nag ass
tell her they step right up what's the
best romantic advice you've ever gotten
and don't be stingy the best romantic
advice I've ever gotten is to be honest
with myself and with the people that you
deal with you know be straight up about
what you're looking for about what your
situation is if you're in a relationship
if you're getting out of one if you're
in an open relationship or close
relationship whatever your situation is
be forthright about it because the other
person needs to know and they should
give you the same
[Music]
[Music]